les obsèques dylan halimi ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui c'est donc à bagneux qu'il
aurait été détenu pendant plusieurs
semaines et torturé par des jeunes qui
ont grandi dans les cités de cette
commune des quartiers où didier briand
et loïc works se sont rendus pour tenter
d'en savoir plus youssef fofana le chef
présumé du gang et ce soir toujours en
fuite
à 26 ans le cerveau des barbares comme
il se fait appeler est extrêmement
dangereuse selon la police ce matin les
enquêteurs étaient venus l'interpeller
chez lui dans cette cité de bagneux
mais ils se seraient volatilisés il ya
deux semaines devant l'appartement
nous tentons de discuter avec ses
parents les voisins parlent d'une
famille discrète et sans histoire
y compris au sujet du fils us f1
mes parents m'ont sont des gens qui
travaillent qui partent trek ton qui
rentre tard je connais bien la petite
jeune fille la petite soeur du jeune
fille adorable est toujours seul tous
temps changent
j'avais toujours seul nom mais jamais de
l'ami un autre chose d'aller à la cabine
est derrière ses complices présumés ont
été arrêtés ce matin principalement dans
cette cité de bagneux
ils ont entre 17 et 32 ans la plupart
sans emploi les policiers parlent de
jeunes sans repères pratiquant une
extrême violence
on a affaire donc à des gens qui sont
issus et qui sok-yong randy qui sont
allés à l'école et au collège dans une
même cité et qui au fil des années
semblent avoir constitué
ce qu'on appelait avant une association
de malfaiteurs une organisation
criminelle voir maintenant un gang l'un
des membres a pris certainement dû à sa
personnalité
une autorité naturelle les enquêteurs de
la brigade criminelle ont quatre jours
pour mieux cerner les personnalités les
motivations des membres présumés du gang
dans la sphère de l'assassinât de
géraldine giraud et de katia lherbier
une confrontation inédite en ce moment
même à sens
le principal suspect jean pierre treiber
est interrogé en compagnie des autres
mises en examen
marie christine van kempen et patricia
darbeau l'objectif de cet interrogatoire
est de savoir si ces trois personnes
s'étaient rencontrés avant l'assassinât
comme l'affirment un témoin